[音楽]
私は長崎市出身で今も長崎に住んでい
ます美しい自然美味しい
食事幻想的な
夜景溢れる魅力があるその一方で1945
年8月9日一発の原子爆弾によって深い傷
を追い平和を祈るための場所でもあります
この記憶を継承するため長崎市内の学校で
は原爆について学ぶ機会がたくさんあり
ます毎年8月9日になれば被爆者の方が
学校を訪れ公演をし
ますあの時は食料がなくて本当に大変だっ
た全身に大を追ってとても痛かっ
た家族は悲惨な姿で水を求めながら死んで
いっ
た道端には黒焦げになってまるで炭のよう
に転がっている遺体があっ
た私はそんな話を聞くのが正直辛いと感じ
ていまし
たそんな戦争体験を身近に感じたことが
あり
ますそれは御年91歳の私の祖父の言葉
です彼は被爆者ではないですが1945年
の第2次世界大戦中日本の空気を知って
いる人
です彼は中学生の頃兵器工場に学都動員さ
れていたそう
です毎日同じ作業に疲れはて過酷な環境で
の労働を強いられている中での昼休み
同じ工場で働いていた女子高校生たちは
履いている地味なモンペをスカートに
履き替えておしゃれを楽しんでいたそう
ですそのことを振り返って祖父
はとても素敵やったねすごく綺麗やった
そう笑顔をこぼしながら振り返っている彼
の姿が今でも目に焼きついてい
ますその時に発とさせられたの
ですパッションが大好きな今の女の子たち
と何にも変わら
ない毎日今日は何を着ていこうかと楽しみ
ながら服を選ぶ私と何にも変わら
ないそんなことを気づいたのです
時代を超えて会ったことのない彼女たちと
なんだかお友達になったようなそんな気が
しまし
た今から78年前人間の手によって作られ
た原爆の下には同じ人間が人間として生き
ていまし
た昨年の9月イギリスのマンチェスターで
開催されたワンヤングワールドという国際
サミットに参加をしまし
た若者のダボス会議とも呼ばれるもので
世界中から若者2000名以上の参加者が
1つの場所に集まって社会問題や私たちの
未来について議論をするそんな場所でし
たいろんな国の人たちと熱く語り合った4
日間
夜にはお酒を片手に肩を組んで踊りまし
たその時ふとこう感じたの
ですもし戦争になればこの人たちと
あらゆる武器を使って殺し合いをしなけれ
ばならないそんなの絶対に嫌だというより
私にはできないと思いまし
たさて皆さんにとって平和とは何でしょう
か戦争がないこと差別がない
こと毎日美味しいご飯が食べられること
大好きな人と一緒にいられる
ことこれこれれこういう状態が平和である
そんな明確な定義は存在しませ
ん皆さんの心の中にある大切なもの守り
たいものそれが平和なの
です今まさにこの瞬間も人間同士の
殺し合いが続いてい
ます私は戦争を体験したことがありませ
ん戦争によって身近な家族や友人を失った
経験もありませ
んなのでどれだけ本を読んでも
どれだけ現地の映像やニュースを見て
もどれだけ話を聞いて
も私は完全に理解することはできませ
んイメージすることはできても共感する
ことはできませ
んこれはある種仕方がないことだとも思っ
てい
ますただ仕方がないで終わらせてしまう
ことはとても危険であることも同時に確信
をしてい
ます不可能であるからこそ自分に何が
できるのか何をすべきなの
かできる限り知って考えるその努力を
続けるべきだと思っていますし私自身も今
もそしてこれからも勤めていきたいと思っ
てい
ます今この動画を見てくれているそこの
あなたも平和を作る一員なの
です平和を実現することができる可能性で
満ち溢れる1人なの
です私もそんな1人の人間として平和の
ために耳を傾け
ます対話し引き続き発信し続け
ます
OG